Роланд Берауер запам'ятав той день назавжди
21 серпня 1968 року
Радянські танки на вулицях чехословацької столиці
"Празька весна" - мрія про свободу -
придушена силою
Берауер - зараз йому 82 роки
бачив усе на власні очі
Він зробив багато фотографій того дня
коли радянське керівництво вирішило
придушити празьке повстання
Незадовго до того війська Організації
Варшавського договору провели навчання
а потім радянська влада відправила
танки до центру Праги
Таким чином Чехословаччину силою змусили
повернутися до тоталітарної моделі соціалізму
Одним з найважливіших об'єктів тоді вважалася радіостанція в Празі
Від початку демократичних реформ у Чехословаччині
журналісти могли там працювати
не боячись цензури
Ми хотіли тоді не допустити захоплення радіостанції
Тому там звели барикади
а тут - підпалили танк
Після введення військ у Прагу
вщент розбилася мрія про "соціалізм з людським обличчям" і для Роланда Берауера
До того ж деякі соціалістичні країни особливо активно підтримували Кремль
у придушенні "Празької весни"
Наприклад, керівництво НДР
Там боротися проти демократичних
реформ у Чехословаччині
почали за кілька місяців до введення танків
Докази цьому можна знайти в архіві документів
міністерства держбезпеки НДР - "штазі"
Тут працює Олівер Штрюбінґ
він досліджує величезну кількість
матеріалів тих часів
Передусім - фотографії, їх понад тисячу
Особливо знімки, зроблені агентами "штазі"
Співробітників "штазі" тоді справді змушували
фотографувати усі протестні акції
щоб потім проти їхніх учасників
можна було відкривати справи
Інформація, здобута "штазі"
можливо, передавалася у служби держбезпеки
інших країн Варшавського договору
Ці знімки донині ніколи не показували по телебаченню
Фотографії почали аналізувати
лише кілька років тому
А це знову Прага
архів колишньої Служби держбезпеки
Ондржей Матейка - заступник директора
Празького Інституту вивчення тоталітарних режимів
Він досліджує історію чехословацьких спецслужб
68-й рік у сприйнятті людей - це досі шок,
пов'язаний з окупацією
Тобто 21 серпня і кілька днів після цієї дати
коли люди пасивно чинили опір
коли вони об'єдналися як суспільство
це було дуже і дуже сильно
Ці події нагадують про себе і нині
Ми показуємо Ондржею
список агентів "штазі" з НДР
які працювали в Празі
Історик не дуже здивований
адже такі шпіони були у всіх країнах
Варшавського договору
Після "Празької весни" спецслужби отримали ще більше влади
Сьогодні минуле знову сколихнуло чехів
дослідники вважають, що чинний прем'єр Чехії Андрей Бабіш
свого часу міг працювати на спецслужби
Бабіш був співробітником вищої категорії,
тобто агентом
Сам Бабіш такі звинувачення відхиляє
Політик-мільярдер виступив із заявою на телеканалі, який йому ж і належить
Якщо в ЗМІ пишуть, що я програв суд у справі про спецслужби
то це брехня
Петр Пітгарт обіймав посаду
голови уряду Чехословаччини
на початку дев'яностих,
коли тоталітарна система впала
Той факт, що через 50 років після "Празької весни"
тінь соціалістичного минулого знову наздогнала чехів, його дуже засмучує
Я вже багато років займаюся питанням
колективної пам'яті
Це для мене цікава, але водночас і сумна тема
Бабіш повторює одне й те саме, у нього сильна команда маркетологів
які радять йому не ризикувати
і не використовувати складні формулювання
Він весь час повторює:
брехня, цілеспрямована брехня, кампанії
Але і для Роланда Берауера, свідка "Празької весни"
спогади про злочини агентів Москви у Чехословаччині
сьогодні такі ж болючі, як і тоді
У серпні 1968 року йому вдалося
таємно передати свої фотографії журналістам із Західної Німеччини
Це було справді просто жахливо
Від придушення "Празької весни" минуло 50 років
Але тінь минулого досі не полишає Чехію